[Music]  Kim Kardashian goes for break the  internet round two and is apparently  feuding with Lindsay Lohan it was a  world with the mother of three shared a  jaw-dropping topless photo on Twitter  Monday posing in skimpy underwear and an  open fur coat other images from the racy  spread included a shower pic and another  one showing off her thong I want to wear  things that make me feel good about  myself and still feel sexy she captioned  one image Bo West as a nod and  recreation of actress and model Bo  Derek's look in the 1979 movie ten so  guys I did not surprisingly much of the  internet was not into it calling Kim out  for cultural appropriation but the one  person Kim clap back at was Lindsay  Lohan Perez Hilton screenshot and shared  this exchange between Kim and Lindsay  Lindsay commenting quote I'm confused  and Kim clapping back with you know  what's confusing your sudden foreign  accent  you